WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi.
My name is Wayne
Piekarski, and I
work as a developer
advocate at Google.
Today I'm going to
talk about Android Wear
and how you can take advantage
of stacking notifications.
Existing notifications,
such as inbox style or those
that use similar
summary information,
can be easily modified with
just a few small changes
to your code.
This allows you to show
additional information
on a wearable device
that's easily glancable.
These notifications
will appear as a stack
on the wearable, allowing
the user to view and take
actions on each
one individually,
or without having to pull
your phone out of your pocket.
Before we get started, make sure
you viewed the previous videos
introducing development
of Android Wear.
There's more
information and access
to the developer preview
available from our website
here.
So now, I'm going to
work through an example
of a simple messaging
system for your pets.
So these are my two awesome
dogs, Mila and Dillon here,
and they're going to be
starring in this video.
So let's say the dogs
are wearing smart collars
during the day which can
send notifications to you.
On the phone, the notifications
are shown together
with the total number showing in
the phone's notification area.
When you click on
the notification,
this brings up the application
to show all the details.
On a wearable, it
would be really cool
if we could look at each one
separately and perhaps take
some specific action or
ignore it until later.
Then there's no need to pull
the phone out of our pocket.
So in this demo, you
can see both the phone
and a wearable emulator
running together.
On the phone, a
notification is showing.
And on the wearable,
you can see there's
a stack notification made
up from multiple events.
You can touch the
notification and it
will expand into
separate messages.
You can touch the
specific notification
and then swipe it to the
side to see possible actions.
And when you use an
action, that notification
will be dismissed, if
it's been specified
to do that in your code.
You can then take
a similar action
on any remaining notifications.
And remember, this can all be
done while your phone remains
in your pocket by interacting
with your wearable device.
So let's work
through the code that
was used to create this example.
Firstly, this is the code
that you would already
be using to create a
notification appearing
on your phone.
One of the nice things
about the Android Wear API
is that it leverages much
of your existing code.
Now, we create a notification
that uses a group key string.
This is a global identifier
that Android uses to know,
which notification should
be grouped together
on the wearable.
It can be any string
that you want.
This is the first
notification that
will appear on the wearable.
You start off by creating the
intent and the pending intent
with whatever result you want.
This is exactly the
same as you would
do for your existing
notifications.
You then create the notification
with the specific details
of the message, in
exactly the same way
that you would have done
it with your existing code.
Note that this
notification is never
meant to appear on the
phone, only on the wearable.
And we use the
code of said action
to indicate an intent for
when an action icon is
touched on the wearable display.
You then need to build a
notification for the wearable
with a code of setGroup, which
puts it in the group specified
previously with the
string constant.
This is the second notification
that appears on the wearable.
The code's basically the
same except the message text
and the action are different.
And finally, we issue
the notifications
to Android so they appear on
the phone and the wearable.
We issue all three of them
separately with unique ID
numbers.
This part of the code issues
the group notification appearing
on the phone and
would probably already
be in your existing code.
Make sure you use a
NotificationManagerCompat
instead of the
notificationManager
from the framework when you're
dealing with wearable devices.
And now, we can issue
the notifications
for the wearable device.
And that's it.
We're done with this example.
So you can see how easy it
is to add stack notifications
to your applications.
Most of your code and APIs
used remains the same,
and you can just add
a little bit more
to specify the grouping.
You can use stacks in
any application that
might generate many
notifications that you'd
want to group together.
So some examples could
be an email client,
an instant messaging
application, and so forth.
There are so many other
cool possibilities
of what you can do here.
This is really just the start
of what I've shown here.
Android Wear is really
exciting new technology,
that's going to allow all kinds
of really neat applications
from developers just like you.
So you can find out more about
Android Wear, and the developer
preview, by visiting
our website.
You should also join our Google+
community and share your ideas
with everyone there.
I'm Wayne Piekarski, and
I'm really looking forward
to seeing what kinds of awesome
ideas you'll come up with.
So thanks for watching.
And I'll see you next time.